they good
they're good hey
you have to see this
[Music]
amazing right
it's beautiful
foreign
[Music]
so
cool
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my video for the new
marvel disney plus series they just
announced for agents of sword and nick
fury
that's right they finally confirmed that
they're doing the new series so we'll
break it down there's a bunch of easter
eggs i'll explain how it's connected to
all the other marvel phase 4 movies and
what's going on with avengers 5.
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos of
course i'll do episode videos for it
when it releases and i will explain
what their release schedule is going to
be for some of this stuff we'll do a new
disney plus giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and let me
know which other avengers characters you
want to see cross over to this agents of
swords series
so just starting with number five big
news first marvel recently announced
that they were doing a full-blown
nick fury disney plus series with samuel
l jackson set
after the events of avengers end game
effectively that is their agents of
sword tv show that had been rumored for
a long time
remember the avengers infinity war post
credit scene with that pager
on the back of the pager you can
actually see it says
sword on it so they've been setting this
up the whole time
there had also been separate rumors
about a nick fury disney plus show
since avengers infinity war a couple
years ago now we can say that those two
rumors were basically about the same
thing
the nick fury series is the agents of
sword follow-up
that clipped from the end of agents of
shield is basically them teasing that
quake is now on deep space missions
she's not working for shield anymore
officially so that means she's working
for sword
and coulson who's kind of like the life
model decoy version of colson has a
brand new version of lola just flies off
into the sunset
teasing his new missions that he's going
on in the side you may have noticed that
marvel was also posting about sword
on all their official social accounts
this morning right as i was making this
video
i see you marvel i see what you're doing
there so yes of course this is them
teasing that they're doing sword in a
really big way on disney plus
there's also a bunch of other sword
scenes between the spider-man far from
home post credit scene
obviously that i put at the beginning of
this video with nick fury on the sword
space station
from the comics and in the one division
trailer that we just got
number four in the one division trailer
you see monica rambo dressed in full
1960s 1970s looking at tire with the
afro getting punted out of scarlet
witch's false bubble dimension the fake
reality where vision is alive and she's
living out her perfect family life with
him
it's like the tom king vision run but
that's basically them doing a couple
different easter eggs at the same time
so one is an easter egg for monica rambo
in the classic comics she was a version
of captain marvel a long time ago
during that era when she would have been
dressed like this in real life
but when all the agents seem like
they're rolling up to check her out
after she crash lands back on earth in
the normal mcu dimension
they're supposed to be a team of sword
agents you actually notice that this
version of monica rambo dressed in sword
gear standing right there so it's
actually two different scenes it's not
two different versions of monica rambo
looking at each other this is just the
way they cut the trailer to make it look
like it was all happening in the same
moment
so monica rambo is an agent of sword
during present day
in the mcu but this one division trailer
footage is just meant to let you know
that the sword
agency is officially making its debut on
one division during marvel phase four
we're going to get those episodes in a
couple months
yes we did get the teaser in the
spider-man far from home post-credits
scene
but since wandavision is the first time
we'll be seeing the sword logo
officially appear that's the series
where they'll explain what nick fury has
been doing since he was snapped back
into avengers end game by the hulk like
this is monica rambo on the set behind
the scenes these are some other agents
of sword some security men you see the
logo
in the background so one division will
do a really good job of explaining
what's going on with that agency
and remember kat dennings darcy from the
thor movies
she's also part of the one division
series she's a scientist so she's also
probably working for sword
i wouldn't be surprised if eric selvig
was working with them too now
so number three essentially what the
spider-man far from home post credit
scene was supposed to tell you was that
not only was nick fury on vacation
kind of a funny moment but he'd also
been working with the scrolls for a long
time now probably since the events of
the captain marvel movie in the 90s when
he first got the tesseract
and at some point after he started
working with them they started building
a larger more sophisticated space
station cloaked in earth's orbit
to replace marvel's secret research ship
that the scrolls
took you don't build space stations
overnight so when it shows up at the end
of spider-man far from home it means
they've been working on that for a long
time
just a couple of the reasons why nick
fury would have done something like that
started a project that big building a
big space station in earth's orbit
would mostly have been the threat that
ronan and the cree made at the end of
the movie the supreme intelligence
marvel yon raag they all
vowed revenge we will return someday it
also you may have missed it during the
spider-man far from home post-credits
scene
talos and his wife slip in a really
subtle mention
of cree sleeper cells on earth which i
think was a teaser for avengers secret
invasion stuff
they're also telling you in this scene
that all the big avengers level threats
that they'll be dealing with in avengers
down the road will be cosmic level
threats coming from outer space
that gets into stuff that they'll deal
with in the eternals movie the new
fantastic four movie and beyond
like galactus level threats and in the
comics
sword is like the next evolution of
shield shield was originally designed to
deal with the threats on planet earth
the sword acronym stands for sentient
world
observation and response department the
reason why we haven't seen sword before
is because
technically the x-men people owned that
and that belonged at fox for a long time
till marvel just got the rights back
marvel has the rights back now so they
can do whatever they want to with it
which is why you see it show up in the
spider-man far from home post-credits
scene
number two shield still does exist nick
fury just isn't spending a lot of time
dealing with them because it's being run
by mack now they even gave him a nick
fury looking trench coat in a new
helicarrier
the disney plus avengers spin-off shows
won't really be following up with him
that much
for those of you wondering how many of
the agents of shield characters will
show up on this nick fury agent of
swords series chloe bennett said that
she was hoping to return
for sword stuff on the disney play shows
but she's been pretty quiet as to
whether or not she knows if they're
going to bring her back
it's going to be a couple years before
we actually see episodes of this nick
fury sword series so they're probably
not going to talk too much about that
this year or even next year maybe but
number one i know you're all asking
which other avengers characters are
gonna cross over onto the show
because it is a big avenger spin-off
show
we probably won't see episodes until
late 2022 or early 2023
so we'll have already gotten almost
every single marvel phase 4 movie in at
least 8
different avengers disney plus series by
then unless they flip the order
way down the road that includes the
black widow movie shang chi
eternals spider-man 3 thor 4 love and
thunder doctor strange 2 multiverse of
madness
1 division falcon and winter soldier
loki marvel's what if series
hawkeye miss marvel moon knight in the
she-hulk series
so any of the new marvel phase 4
characters and surviving avengers like
thor who we know are coming back for
avengers 5 are fair game to show up
and if you missed all the interviews
that samuel l jackson did for spider-man
far from home
people asked him what nick fury is doing
right now after avengers end game he
said that he's actually getting ready to
put another avengers team together
in the background so we'll probably see
him start to do that on this new agents
of sword
nick fury series and obviously i will be
doing all the one division episode
videos we also have the mandalorian
season 2 episodes starting in a couple
weeks
so as long as you have alerts enabled
for my channel you should see all those
videos when i post them
congratulations ea you're the giveaway
winner from my last big marvel giveaway
please email me on the about page of my
channel so i can get your contact
details
everyone click here for that brand new
avengers one division trailer
and click here for the marvel shang chi
movie teaser
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you